herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie heute mit einem gast dessen
bücher sie kennen oder zumindest schon
stapelweise in den buchhandlungen haben
liegen sehen
zu gast ist nämlich ferdinand von
schirach einer der erfolgreichsten
deutschsprachigen schriftsteller als
strafverteidiger hat er jahrzehntelang
an der seite der mörder vergewaltiger
und sadisten gestanden um die innenleben
zu ergründen versucht herzlich
willkommen herr von schirach er von
schirach jeder kam zum schwerverbrecher
werden sagen sie auch ich ja dann können
wir das alle
es ist einfach so dass wir wissen müssen
dass in fast allen fällen also es gibt
ganz selten ausnahme aber in fast allen
fällen die umstände die tat gebühren
also sie kommen irgendwann auch wenn sie
das heute jetzt in diesem hübschen tisch
überhaupt nicht vermuten in so eine
situation aus der sie keinen ausweg mehr
wissen und und das wird oft als tunnel
beschrieben
das ist sozusagen gar keine wege mehr
gibt links und rechts und dann kommt es
manchmal zu einem verbrechen und das
seltsame ist dass das leuten passiert
von denen wir das überhaupt nicht
glauben ja also es gibt auch natürlich
berufsverbrecher die sich dass sie
morgens sich vornehmen wir begehen heute
straftaten und machen überfälle oder
sonst was aber so die die die straftaten
die interessanten können jedem passieren
sie beschreiben in vielen ihrer
erzählungen ja genau auch dieses
phänomen wie eigentlich ganz
unbescholtene menschen vor sich hin
leben und dann werden sie vielleicht
beschimpft oder gekränkt dem oft
gehänselt irgendetwas läuft schief und
irgendwann ist so viel schief gelaufen
was das fass überläuft
gibt es da eben einen generellen grund
warum das fass überläuft oder was ist
aus macht das dann der tunnelblick zu
dieser tat ziehen
vielleicht kann man es am besten mit
einem beispiel erzählen
stellen sie sich vor sie haben sich in
einen mann verliebt und sie wissen ganz
genau
dass sie alles mögliche tun dürfen aber
ihn nicht nach dem abendessen auch noch
anrufen nach dem ersten date sie fanden
das netz das war alles ein schöner abend
und irgendwie möchten sie gerne wieder
mit dem sprechen und alles in ihnen sagt
tu es nicht ihre freundin sagen du
darfst ihn jetzt nicht anrufen mache es
nicht und sie sitzen den ersten abend
noch von telefon und und sind ganz
sicher sie machen uns nicht und am
zweiten abend halten sie sich mal aus ja
unternehmen sie den telefonhörer und
rufen ihn an um seine stimme zu hören
und das ist ein hundertstel oder in
tausendstel von den von den mechanismen
die in ihnen ablaufen wenn sie eine
schwere straftaten begehen sie wissen
ziemlich sicher sie dürfen das nicht ja
das ist falsch das zu tun
und irgendwann können sie haben nicht
mehr anders also das ist so ungefähr der
mechanismus ist in diesem beispiel quasi
unklug da anzurufen
dass sie denken man muss dir mal ein
bisschen zappeln lassen aber bei einem
schweren verbrechen ist ja nicht nur
unklug das zu tun sondern sich einfach
auch falsches wertung mannschaft die man
ja natürlich aber das sollte nur
beschreiben dass sie irgendwann auch so
eine situation nicht mehr richtig raus
kommen und stellen sie sich vor eine
eine ganz lange und und einmal hab ich
es so beschrieben sie quält ihn die
ganze zeit und zwar nicht nicht
strafrechtlich relevant sondern nur so
mit kleinen gemeinheiten bosheiten
winzigen setzen die sie sagt und und der
mann schlug das alles ja und versucht zu
sein dass arzt in meiner geschichte und
versucht es so aufrecht zu erhalten so
sein sein bürgerliches leben
und irgendwann an einem morgen nach 50
jahren ehe bricht es einfach durch
hindurch und er kann nicht mehr und dann
passiert so etwas
und das ist dass es jetzt haben als ich
diese geschichte geschrieben habe war
das so ein anfall der
ähnlich abgelaufen ist vor vielen jahren
und kurz nachdem ich die geschichte
veröffentlicht hat ist selber nochmal
passiert ja also es ist eine gewisse
häufigkeit und die motive ähneln sich
irgendwann es gibt natürlich genauso gut
umgekehrt er also müsste man die frau
die ganze zeit das bedeutet ist das was
sie beschreiben ist tatsächlich etwas
was wir alle kennen die frage ist dann
ob sie wirklich zur tat schreiten zur
schlimmen zeiten da geht es ja doch auf
einem noch sozusagen die sichtweise man
sagt es gibt psychopathen und die haben
sozusagen von geburt an sagen gewisse
psychologen auch hier in physiologische
veränderungen das heißt da geht jetzt
nicht darum dass das fass überläuft
sondern da ist wirklich etwas anders bei
diesen menschen das stimmt diese
straftaten sind auch also für mich
zumindest nicht interessant das ist
einfach eine eine krankheit also der der
psychopath der hat er hat einen viel
höhere emotionale schwelle also stellen
sie sich vor sie gehen in ein kaffeehaus
und sie sehen einen schönen apfelkuchen
und sie freuen sich über den apfelkuchen
ja denn dann ist ihre emotionale
abschied ude macht ein ausschlag und der
psychopath empfindet nichts wenn er den
den schönen apfelkuchen sieht und er
empfindet auch nichts bei einem normalen
sex und nicht bei irgendeiner anderen
freude die er hat sondern es muss etwas
viel stärkeres ein stärkerer impuls sein
ja ein stärkerer aus stadt und den hatte
dann wenn er einer frau die haut abzieht
ja dann empfindet er dasselbe was sie
bei dem ansicht des apfel google zu
empfinden und und das ist schrecklich
und furchtbar aber es ist eine krankheit
und und die ist für mich nicht
interessant er also schriftstellerische
interessiert mich überhaupt nicht weil
es das ist gut für für für schweden
krimis oder so etwas und man muss dazu
wissen es gibt ganz wenig psychopathen
ja also
ich habe gelesen ein prozent der
bevölkerung sind also es wird aber auch
behauptet ja was ist mag sein aber wir
haben wir haben sagt man insgesamt in
den gefängnissen etwa 100 weltweit
ja also es ist verschwindend gering und
man bezeichnet oft jemand als
psychopathen wenn er sich so emotional
ungeschickt benimmt und es gibt auch
viele leute die eine niedrigere
emotional schwelle haben aber das sind
noch keine psychopath ja also das ist
das ist wirklich ein sehr seltenes
phänomen
jetzt haben sie gesagt sie interessiert
das nicht weil das ist sozusagen krank
gehören pathologisiert aber die leute da
draußen interessiert das ja schon also
so strafzölle wie zum beispiel fritzl
war so jürgen ein großes ein großer teil
der filiale interessant gehirn haben da
will man ja schon sagen ich weiß nicht
ob das ein psychopath war aber das sind
heute natürlich also so der typische
psychopathin die leute kennen ist
hannibal lecter aus dem film das ist so
ein typisches über und und da
interessiert die leute der grusel ja
dass du das scheußliche und das
unverständliche und aber ich finde es
wahnsinnig langweilig also bei mir auch
mal bei der these jeder kann zum
verbrecher werden aufgrund dieser tunnel
blick haben wir gesagt das ist fast das
sich langsam fühlt warum sind frauen den
statistisch gesehen viel weniger
vertreten im gefängnis und 90 prozent
der gefängnisse weltweiten jahr mit
männern belegt ja also es ist einfach
statistisch so dass frauen viel weniger
straftaten begehen ja dass das war zwar
in allen ländern interessanterweise und
es gibt ganz viele untersuchungen
darüber weil es natürlich alle
interessiert warum begehen frauen
weniger straft hat und es gibt eine
fülle von erklärungen dazu also
beispielsweise die soziale prägung alles
möglich ich habe noch keine gefunden die
mich wirklich befriedigt hat aber man
weiß zum beispiel oder klar ist frauen
beginnt weniger gewalttaten
einfach weil sie schwächer sind ja das
ist deswegen schlagen sie nicht einfach
jemand anderen ins gesicht habe weil sie
sie werden gern habe sie keinen sie
können nicht ja und
und man weiß es nicht genau
es gibt auch eine ungerechtigkeit im
strafsystem frauen gegenüber
also wir haben so eine ganz alte
vorstellung von dem hobby wir bestrafen
also mit ist sie begehen ein totschlag
wenn sie jemanden offen gegenübertreten
und der as wehrhaft und sie erstechen
ihnen beispielsweise und das machen
eigentlich nur männer untereinander und
frauen weil sie weil sie schwächer sind
können das nicht also wenn sie einem
mann gegenüber treten würden und mit
einem gezückten messer dann gibt er
ihnen eine ohrfeige und dann ist die
situation entschärft also müssen sie zu
einem heimtückischen mittel greifen zu
gift oder zum zum erschlagen von hinten
oder so etwas
und das bestraft das gesetz härte ja
also es ist im vergleich zu tun das ist
der mord im vergleich das ist ein mord
merkmal das verwirklicht wird das ist
die heimtücke die arg und wehrlosigkeit
und das ist natürlich totaler unsinn ja
also ich glaube ich würde lieber von
hinten erschlagen werden ohne dass ich
etwas mitbekommen als das auch noch
vorherzusehen
aber unsere gesellschaft sagte er es ist
es ist fairer einem einem anderen mit
hochgeklappten visier gegenüberzutreten
also stand wirklich aus der zeit totaler
quatsch aber da werden frauen zum
beispiel benachteiligt weil sie
sozusagen weniger kraft haben weil sie
schwächen gegenschlag der giftmord ist
etwas was hauptsächlich von frauen
gegangen
und das ist ja diesen dass es sozusagen
diese unterschiede ein fall der in der
schweiz sehr sehr viel zu reden gab wie
jetzt gerade ihn jetzt auch wieder heiß
diskutiert und zwar ist das der fall von
mischa ebner und der fall diente auch
einer grundlage für einen neuen film von
hans baumgartner und zwar ist das der
fahrer neben mischa ebner
der film heißt der läufer und er läuft
gerade jetzt in den kinos an wir sehen
hier die originale
nicht die kinobilder sondern die
originalbilder von michaela er war ein
langstreckenläufer ein waffen läufer
ergeht aus extrem freundlich viele haben
beschrieben wie zuvorkommend er war wie
ein unglaublich freundlicher mensch war
koch und hat sie viele freunde die ihm
sehr sehr geschätzt haben und das
erschrecken die an diesem fall so viele
leute beschäftigt und was auch in diesem
film sehr gut herauskommt ist dass man
sich fragt wie kann so etwas passieren
wie ist es wie ist es möglich dass ein
mensch der so ein unbescholtenes leben
auf der einen seite führt auf der
anderen seite solche raubdelikte begeht
und schlussendlich hat er auch eine frau
gewürgt dass sie beinahe gestorben wäre
und eine andere frau erstochen
also in den 30 jahren in meinen beiden
berufen habe ich eigentlich nur eine
sache gelernt nämlich dass der mensch
ein ambivalentes wesen ist ja alle haben
anteile von guten und bösen in uns und
zwar jeder ja also die die vorstellung
jemand sein nur gut oder nur böse ist so
eine vorstellung die die ganz naiv ist
und die die mit der wirklichkeit nichts
zu tun hat für comics ist das gut aber
sonst sonst nicht und und das schöne ist
dass der mensch trotzdem so ein halbwegs
plausibles ganzes ergibt aber wir wissen
das doch immer wieder von politikern die
das ist das offensichtlichste diese ganz
fein und erscheinen und anständig und 2
und dann hören wir plötzlich dass sie
steuern hinterzogen haben oder oder sich
in die eigene tasche gewirtschaftet
haben also die vorstellung dass jemand
nur eine seite hat ist plötzlich ja es
ist in uns allen beides und manchmal
überwiegt die eine oder die andere seite
plötzlich in einer situation und so
ich kenne in diesem fall nicht aber der
junge mann hat ja offensichtlich so ein
erfolgreiches leben auf der einen seite
geführt was nicht ganz zu raubtaten
passt weil die meisten raubtaten
tatsächlich aus einer aus einer
wirtschaftlichen idee heraus begangen
werden weil man einfach mehr geld haben
will ohne geld braucht es gibt
allerdings zum beispiel bei dem kaufhaus
diebstahl begehen ja oft ganz
wohlhabende frauen ja das ist ein sehr
typisches frauen willi und die klauen
eine kleine flasche parfüm
diddy 40 schweizer franken kostet also
blödsinn dass die trauer die klauen sind
millionärin und das hat das hat so eine
entlastungsfunktion ja man spielt diese
diese flasche und das einzige mal in
diesem ganz langweiligen leben in dem
alles so gesittet ist hat man eine
spannung nämlich dass man erwischt wird
vielleicht ja okay geben ein paar angler
ganz genau und und und dann gibt es
daneben interessanterweise noch ganz
viele straftaten bei denen man das nicht
sofort und auf den ersten blick sieht
die die einen einen sexuellen
hintergrund haben die man den menschen
auch nicht ansieht ja sie wissen nicht
was was leute abends in ihrem wohnzimmer
sicher auf ihren laptops anschauen das
können sie einfach nicht sagen etwas was
in diesem film mich sehr berührt ist die
einsamkeit dieser figuren und das ist
etwas was ich auch ein stück weit durch
ihr werk zieht was immer wieder vorkommt
dass die figuren mit gewissen dingen
einfach nicht zurecht kommen und in
diesem spezifischen fall ist dass der
selbstmord des bruders er hat eine ganz
schwere kindheit wurde dann adoptiert
dieser mischer ebner
aber der selbstmord des bruders der
taucht immer wieder auf in träumen auch
in albträumen dieser läufer hat und man
fragt sich wie könnte man daraus finden
ohne sozusagen eine straftat begehen zu
müssen war das ja vielleicht auch wie
ein ventil sein
also die einsamkeit ist ja etwas was wir
alle spüren ja wir tun immer so als
wären wir nicht einen sagen und uns
gewählt ist auch darauf eingerichtet
dass wir möglichst wenig einsamkeit
empfinden also wenn sie zum beispiel von
einem kreuzfahrtschiff die kataloge
lesen er da steht dann dass sie dauernd
ihre freunde treffen oder irgendwelche
freunde die sind bis dahin noch gar
nicht kannten usw und man man will so
ein leben haben und stellt sich das als
besonders großartig vor das nicht einsam
ist aber die wirklichkeit ist auch wenn
wir das für uns selbst sogar schwer zu
geben kann dass die meisten menschen
einsam sind ja und da raus zu finden ist
schwierig ich glaube auch dass es gar
nicht geht letztlich ist vielleicht die
bessere einstellung dazu dass man das
akzeptiert dass man sagt ja es ist
einfach so wir sind einsam ja wir haben
wir haben lange strecken in unserem
leben und zwar auch selbst stellen wir
mit einem partner zusammen sind wir
liegen im bett und beim einschlafen sind
wir nein sagen ja aber wenn einsam
gehört zum menschsein dazu gehört warum
denken wir denn ein einsamer mensch ist
bedauernswert
das ist die moderne ja also wir wollen
sozusagen ein helles freundliches
aufregendes leben ja aber das leben ist
nicht so erst sonne und und wir wir
versuchen von der unterhaltungsindustrie
von den von den
ganz denen der moderne anders zu sein
aber es funktioniert dies gelingt uns
nicht die einsamkeit bleibt ja und es
wird gesellschaftlich ein bisschen
verachtet das einsam sein genauso wie
zum beispiel das nicht arbeiten
verachtet wird er haben wir alle leute
tun ja immer so als seien sie wahnsinnig
beschäftigt jetzt wenn das 1 1
menschsein gehört kann man dann trotzdem
sagen die einsamkeit hat zugenommen was
würde man ja denken wenn man sich zum
beispiel vor augen führt dass
großbritannien ein ministerium
einsamkeit geschaffen habe also da geht
es wirklich darum politisch etwas zu
unternehmen gegen ein phänomen von dem
sie denken das ist ganz viele menschen
extrem bedroht und eben mehr bedroht als
früher
ich glaube das ist was anderes ich
glaube da geht es um das alleinsein ja
was etwas anderes ist als das einsam
sein
das allein ist ein die meisten menschen
in städten leben mittlerweile in nicht
mehr in paarbeziehungen sondern haben
eine eigene wohnung in zwei oder drei
zimmern in denen sie wohnen und das
meint dieses ministerium dass man da für
diese leute gemeinschaftsräume sozusagen
schaffen muss vereine irgendetwas wo sie
bietet zusammenhang das ist allein sein
die einsamkeit
sie können auch ganz einsam sein denn
sie da und mit vielen menschen zusammen
sind auch mit in einer partnerschaft
sind viele menschen wahnsinnig einsam
weil sie überhaupt nicht mehr über sich
reden können
das ist so eine art fremdheit die einen
geführt genau was ich darüber
nachgedacht habe weil ich das sehr
interessant finde was ich zur einsamkeit
sagen ist mir ein text in den sinn
gekommen nämlich von odo marquard einen
philosophen den ich sehr schätze
in dem büchlein ist skepsis und
zustimmung das plädoyer für die
einsamkeit fähigkeit und er würde
wahrscheinlich genauso wie sie sagen
einsam werden wir immer ein stück weit
sein das ist gar nichts schlechtes über
was schlecht ist ist wenn ihr mit der
einsamkeit nicht umgehen können und sie
nicht produktiv nutzen was ja eigentlich
wieder lernen müssen ist eben eine
fähigkeit zur einsamkeit und vielleicht
könnte man ja sagen diese fähigkeit zur
einsamkeit ist umso wichtiger also wir
mehr allein sind wie sie vorhin
also ich bin ganz gegen produktives
nutzen ja findet sozusagen
wir müssen nicht alles immer produktiv
nutzen sondern sondern ist es einfach
gut das auszuhalten wenn man das weiß
also ist es so wie wenn sie schnupfen
haben ja und wenn sie das erste mal
es ist nicht vorstellbar aber sie haben
das erste mal schnupfen und ihre nase
läuft und ihre augen schwellen an und
sie können schlecht schlucken und es ist
alles irgendwie unangenehm und sie
wissen nicht was das ist und dann kommt
ein arzt sagt es ist nicht so schlimm es
ist nur schnupfen
ja es ist in ein paar tagen wieder
vorbei können sie damit ganz gut leben
ja und wenn wir wenn wir akzeptieren das
teil des menschseins die einsamkeit ist
und die fremdheit mit den dingen und und
dass das uneins seien mit der welt es
ist okay dann können sie damit ganz gut
leben ja sagen sie gesagt ich bin ein
bisschen gegen produktiv naja was ich
interessant also dass sie finden
generell wir sollten mehr einfach
aushalten ja immer was besseres draus
macht ja also das geht ja ein bisschen
weg jetzt von dem thema aber wenn wir
wenn wir wenn wir überlegen
ich habe ihn ja vorhin gesagt ich glaube
dass das der mensch ein ambivalentes
wesen ist und unsere gesellschaft ist
das eigentlich auch ja also wir leben ja
in einer vollkommen zerrissenen
gesellschaft wir sind uns uneins über
sehr viele dinge es ist es gibt alle
möglichen verschiedenen strömungen
glauben an gott oder allah oder das
fliegende spaghettimonster oder nur an
uns selbst also ist jeder tut ein
bisschen etwas anderes und und
vielleicht ist das der westen und dann
wäre es schön wenn wir das akzeptieren
können nämlich nicht der konsens sondern
das aushalten eines des hens und und
wenn wir das wenn wir das akzeptieren
dass anders als in totalitären staaten
oder
und neben china oder nehmen wir nehmen
wir nehmen wir die türkei jetzt moment
das ist noch kein totalitärer staat aber
es geht in die richtung
denn dann geht es immer dort um den
konsens und bei uns kann es ruhig um den
dissens gehen ist es doch toll wenn wir
unterschiedlicher meinung sind ja nun
müssen wir das aushalten und nicht in
anderen bekämpfen und mit der einsamkeit
ist ein bisschen so den bogen wieder zu
kriegen
das wäre so was wie plädoyer für
toleranz im sinne von aushalten dass sie
unterschiedlich denke aber es gibt auch
dieses plädoyer für sage ich doch einmal
einsamkeit nämlich aushalten dass wir
auch fremd sind in unserer eigenen welt
ja wir müssen müssen das einfach die
psychiater seine bewusst machen ja also
wenn wir wenn wir uns klar darüber sind
dass die welt so ist ja und dass sie
dass wir es nicht ändern
stellen sie sich doch mal vor wir leben
auf diesem winzigen planet ja in unserem
welt also sollen es nur in unserer
galaxie so dass 100 milliarden solcher
sonnensysteme geben und von diesen
galaxien soll es ebenfalls 100
milliarden geben und dazwischen ist es
leer und kalt
es bleibt einsam wir können daran nichts
ändern und das lustige akzeptieren ich
habe ein bild mitgebracht
ja man stimmt mir wenn ich uns mehr von
caspar david friedrich sie sagen dass
sie dieses bild ganz ganz oft angestellt
haben stundenlangen die
nationalbibliothek während des
schreibens von kabul
eines ihrer großen bücher und das ist
genau das was wir ja und dass das
interessante ist übrigens auf diesem auf
diesem bild das caspar david friedrich
zuerst noch ein segelschiff gemalt hatte
in dem bild und dann ihm das aber auch
zu viel war und er hat sogar dieses
segelschiff noch übermalt und und uns
selbst der mann ich den würde man heute
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht mehr
unbedingt malen müssen
dieses bild zeigt die einsamkeit und die
fremd hat und dass man aber darin leben
kann es ist nicht so schlimm
es ist auch das ambivalent wir an die
weite sehen wenn man aufgehoben ist oder
die weiten der mann alleine fühle
mir fehlt noch etwas sein was mir
unglaublich gut gefahren hat in ihrem
buch strafe in der letzten geschichte
sprechen die beiden figuren über ein
gedicht von rilke das heißt trägt werden
und da gibt es diesen einen satz siegen
muss nicht alles überstehen ist alles so
ähnlich ist nicht ist das der punkt es
geht nicht ums überwinden uns über es
gehört uns liegen sondern nur ums
überstehen also das ist ein merkwürdiger
satz von riehl gewesen wären
der ist nach dem krieg geschrieben
worden und und in diesem gedicht läuft
es darauf hinaus dass das man überhaupt
nicht singen kann sondern nur die sachen
überstehen kann
ich weiß nicht genau ob das stimmt ja
also das wird ja auch ein bisschen in
der geschichte bezweifelt weil es
manchmal einfach den punkt gibt wo alles
zu viel ist und wo man wo das überstehen
selbst gar nichts mehr bedeutet also
darüber kann man lange streiten aber im
grunde genommen ist es geht es in die
richtige richtung
wir können bestimmen also wir können
unsere freiheit schon nutzen ja wir
können und ich glaube dass die meisten
kunst daraus entstehen ja dass das der
künstler sich uneins ist mit der welt ja
und sich die und die welt sozusagen
schreiben oder musizieren oder malen zu
eigen machen bildung und irgendwann
versteht es funktioniert nicht aber das
mit dass mit der produktivität weil so
gemeint dass ich das ist quatsch finde
alles immer in produktivität umzusetzen
heute wird er gesagt sie können sich
hier entspannen damit sie später
produktive sind nein nein entspannen
sich einfach nur so unfertig
ich habe mich natürlich auch gefragt
dieses ganze interesse an der einsamkeit
man kann auch sagen die empfänglichkeit
für die einsamkeit hat sie bei ihnen
auch etwas zu tun mit ihrer ganz
persönlichen geschichte weil sie auch
beschreiben wie sie aufgewachsen sind in
einem großbürgerlichen haushalt die
kinder haben in der küche gegessen die
erwachsenen im speisesaal
das heißt dieses gefühl von ich bin
eigentlich doch oft auch alleine oder in
einer einzelnen gruppe später daneben
jesuiten internat wo sie auch dieses
fremde gespürt haben den riesigen
schlafsaal zu sein nicht wissen kann ich
wieder nach hause gehen
glauben sie dass sie da spezifisches
kind auch die erfahrung gemacht haben
und sie jetzt weiter beschäftigt das war
es ist ja so wenn wir als kinder
erfahrung machen dann sind sie alle
erstmal neu ja und unmittelbar und war
vor allen dingen und und das was wir
später machen ist das zu interpretieren
aber als kind wenn sie wenn sie einsam
sind merken sie nicht dass sie einsam
sensoren ist es dann im einfach so und
bei uns gab es gar keine
es gab keine alternative wir hatten mit
unseren mit unseren eltern relativ wenig
zu tun es gab so personal das sich um
uns gekümmert hat und damals war es auch
so dass kinder mehr nebenbei liefen in
allen familien ja das war es wurde nicht
diese über behütete kindheit die die
meisten kinder heute erleben und ja das
war so ich ja ich hab das nicht bewerten
können weil ich auch keine alternative
hat was ich dann wo ich zum ersten mal
so gefremdelt das ist ein bayerischer
ausdruck dass das bedeutet so dass man
fremd ist dieses fremdeln hatte ich zum
ersten mal dass ich als jedes internat
kam ich war neun jahre alt und zu hause
war es immer still und weit und und
langsam ja und plötzlich war ich in so
einem internat wo ich mit 30 leuten in
einem schlafsaal lag und das war das
gegenteil der war es laut und schnell
und sehr viele bands ja das war das war
ein bisschen komisch und das bilden
nicht ganz losgeworden ja ich dachte es
ist auch interessant dass sie sich ja
eigentlich auch die rolle des einsamen
dann gesucht haben als strafverteidiger
sie sagen irgendwo auch sie sind immer
allein
wir sind eigentlich david gegen goliath
als strafverteidiger ist dass ihre rolle
das finde ich interessant wie noch nie
darüber nachgedacht aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass sie im gerichtssaal
wirklich alleine sind es gibt ja niemand
ihnen da noch was sagen kann also sind
in einer zeugenbefragung so wie sie
jetzt hier mit mir sitzen kann niemand
sagen
jetzt macht das anderes und stellen
sondern sie stehen da allein im
gerichtssaal und und und es kommt nur
darauf an welche fragen sie jetzt im
zeugen oder dem dem angeklagten oder
irgendjemanden stellt das ist
interessant natürlich weil es eben wie
sie richtig sagen das ist david gegen
goliath auf der anderen seite haben sie
das viel mächtigere gericht und die
vielen mächtigere staatsanwaltschaft und
sie stehen da und haben nur ihren kopf
ja und nur ihre sprache um eine sache
für sich zu entscheiden ob ich das
deshalb gewählt habe weil sie nicht es
ist ein bisschen zu in meiner familie
sind zu die meisten seit 600 jahren
juristen und und deswegen habe ich das
wahrscheinlich auch studieren aber in
dem ganzen juristisch da hat mich dann
nur strafverteidigung interessiert weil
es da um die schuld des menschen geht
und das ist ein interessantes thema ob
jetzt in zivil rechte eine von dem
anderen geld bekommt das wahnsinnig
langweilig über die schuld sprechen wir
nachher gleich noch mich interessiert
auch sie sind ja jetzt nicht mehr als
strafverteidiger tätig sie haben das
sehr sehr lange gemacht sie haben
irgendwann auch einfach gesehen dass sie
erfolg als schriftsteller so groß ist
dass sie sagen als strafverteidiger
könnten sie eigentlich nicht mehr
glaubwürdig sein sie werden dann immer
schon auch noch dieser berühmte herr von
schirach da diese bücher schreibt gibt
es etwas was sie vermissen aus dem
gerichtssaal ja den gerichtssaal
na ja das ist so wissen sie wir machen
überall in der welt dauern kompromisse
ja
also in unserem persönlichen leben in
der politik in der wirtschaft über alles
besteht aus kompromissen ja und das ist
ja auch gut so dass das ist eine
demokratie ist ein kompromiss letztlich
aber im gerichtssaal hören die
kompromisse irgendwann auf der richtung
muss irgendwann entscheiden der war's
oder der war es nicht ja und er muss ihm
irgendwann eine bestimmte strafe geben
die strafverfahren sind begrenzt
irgendwann sn
und diese klarheit und dieses eindeutig
das ist eine der dinge die ich vermisse
und das andere ist die die
intellektuelle herausforderung ja sie
sie haben einen fall der vollkommen
aussichtslos auf den ersten blick
erscheint und und und der freund des
strafverteidigers ist der zufall
ja und sie müssen sehen ob es
irgendetwas gibt was vielleicht auch
anders interpretiert werden kann
das zufällige also das klingt so
abstrakt ständig vor ein mann kommt aus
einem hotelzimmer mit einem blutigen mit
mit einer blutigen hand und in dem
hotelzimmer liegt eine tote frau mit
einem messer in der brust ja jetzt kommt
die staatsanwaltschaft und sagte er ist
eindeutig der hat die umgebracht und
dann kann konnte verteidiger und sagt
nein der kam erst nach dem mord dorthin
und hat die frau gesehen und hat sie
versucht zu deswegen hat dieses blut an
der hand und ist dann daraus gerannt ja
beides ist möglich und das ist und da
wird es dann interessant und jetzt haben
sie gesagt was sie fasziniert ist die
wahrheit die eindeutigkeit aber
gleichzeitig haben sie doch am anfang
gesagt der mensch ist immer ambivalent
immer gut und böse
wie passt das zusammen ja weil ich auch
in berlin keine ausrede ist es ist es
ist wohltuend wenn wir wenn wir etwas
eindeutig es in unserer welt haben und
ich glaube auch eine eine
eine faszination für die gerichtssäle
und für das recht kommt daher dass wir
das wir ein einen punkt haben in unserem
leben entschieden wird wo es nicht
weiter geht als das ende wird wird eine
entscheidung getroffen und das hat etwas
von einem wettbewerb natürlich und und
es ist aber auch gleichzeitig so ein
endpunkt in den ich gerne mag
lassen sie uns darüber ein bisschen
genauer ging sie haben gesagt sie
interessieren sich auch für die schuld
ja und es geht darum auch zu entscheiden
entscheidet man denn im gerichtssaal wer
die schuld trägt
naja es gibt zwei entscheidungen immer
ja also es gibt einmal die entscheidung
der war's oder der war es nicht ja man
muss dazu wissen dass das in den
allermeisten fällen der angeklagte in
einem gerichtsverfahren ist auch sehr
wahrscheinlich war er hat sonst würden
wir ja chaos leben also die polizei
findet schon in der regel denjenigen bei
dem die verdachtsmomente am höchsten
sind und vielleicht in 70 prozent der
strafverfahren die wirklich verhandelt
werden ist es so dass man nicht mehr
lange darüber redet ob das wahr oder
nicht so dass es einfach fest steht und
dann redet man über die zweite sache
nämlich über über die höhe oder die
schwere seiner schuld wie schwer wiegt
das was er getan hat stellen sie sich
vor jemand stiehlt ein apfel und und im
mittelalter war so der hat in dieser
hand hat den apfel gestohlen die hand
hatten wir ab und zwar vollkommen egal
warum der apfel gestohlen worden und
heute fragen wir eben ja hatte den
stühlen weil er hunger hatte hat er ihn
gestohlen weil er verrückt ist und gerne
äpfel sammelt hatte ihn gestohlen weil
der verkäufer des achters ihm den
vorherigen und hat usw
heute interessiert uns also sozusagen
das motiv die deckung dafür und und
damit interessiert uns die schuld ja das
ist der zweite teil und das wunder nicht
und überhaupt nicht früher gab es
einfach ein sogenanntes
tat strafrecht er also eine eine tat
wurde bestraft nach der tat also dem
dieb wurden die hände abgehackt der der
vergewaltiger wurde aufgehängt usw
es ist wahr war einfach auf eine
bestimmte straftat stand eine bestimmte
straf und heute haben wir einen ganz
großen ganz große bandbreite von sind
schön dass das motiv auch mord und
totschlag zu unterscheiden was young
hatten ja aber auch bei bei einem
totschlag selbst bestrafen wir zwischen
wenn es ein minderschwerer fall ist
zwischen etwa drei jahren bis hin zu 15
jahren und es sind ja auch ganz
unterschiedliche dinge also wenn wir in
dem beispiel dass ich vorhin genannt
habe wenn wir diesen alten arzt der
seine alte form gebracht hat bestrafen
die muss ja ganz anders bestraft werden
als 1 1 25 jährige der aus wut einen
obdachlosen erschlägt ja das sind sind
zwei völlig verschiedene straftaten und
wir können nicht dieselbe strafe das hat
uns aber im mittelalter nicht
interessiert und das interessiert jetzt
spezifisch diese motive ja und das ist
dass es gekommen sozusagen durch die
aufklärung ja das war teil der
aufklärung dass wir uns für die schuld
des menschen interessieren sind das ist
die interessanteste frage überhaupt die
finde ich auch extrem interessant und
jetzt interessiert mich aber auch
wiederum dass ich den eindruck hatte in
vielen ihrer geschichten wie mir das gar
nicht so sehr klar und gerade das
fasziniert anja rosiak es gibt zum
beispiel in diesem buch strafe gibt es
eine geschichte die hat mich die musste
ich zweimal oder dreimal lesen sie hat
mich die hat mich so erschüttert da ist
ein mann seine frau stirbt an krebs
ein sehr trauriger mann ist sehr alleine
er verliebt sich in die nachbarin eine
schöne junge frau die hat eigentlich
alles was man ein erfolgreiches leben
nennt da ist ein swimmingpool lasten gut
verdienender mann und tiefe reißt
und was tut er der mann der nachbar
liegt unter seinem wagen und repariert
davon unten sein auto und er geht dahin
und drückt gegen die stoßstange so dass
diese wagenheber einknicken und der wand
wird einfach erdrückt und das
beschreiben sie noch relativ detailliert
was da passiert und man versteht
doch gar nicht was ist das motiv dieses
mal ist das ist ja das grässliche das
ist jeder das fest dass sie bei läuft ja
das ist einfach so einsam
ja und wissen sie viele dinge verstehen
wir tatsächlich nicht ja also es ist ja
ein irrtum zu glauben wir würden die
handlungen der anderen menschen immer
ganz verstehen ja also wir tun oft dinge
die vollkommen sinnlos denn wir geben
auch sinnlose antworten oft auf fragen
wenn sie mal in einem kaffeehaus setzen
und sie hören an einem nebentisch nur
zufällig zu was was dort geredet das ist
komplett sinnfrei ja und das auch teil
des lebens er und und wir das
strafverfahren deswegen habe ich diese
geschichte geschrieben der
strafverfahren gibt uns oft das gefühl
dass der dass der richter etwas logisch
hintereinander erklärt dass das es
passiert dass es deshalb passieren dass
deshalb manchmal gibt's das nicht und
ist denn dieser mann den ich jetzt
gerade beschrieben haben es da schuldig
na ja er hatte also ein totschlag
beziehungsweise in mord begangen und und
wenn das vor gericht kommen käme wäre
ganz sicher verurteilt der witz ist das
ist nie verhandelt worden
dadurch seien geschichten sind ja auch
immer zusammen geschrieben aus ganz
unterschiedlichen fällen nach
beschreibung einzelner fälle sondern sie
kombinieren das darf ich ja nicht also
ich darf nicht irgendwie sozusagen eine
geschichte genauso erzählen wie sie
passiert ist wer auch meistens
langweilig ehrlich gesagt ich stehe
unter schweigepflicht deswegen bietet
sich das von selbst aber ich setze die
geschichten zusammen aus lauter
unterschiedlichen fällen die ich erlebt
habe oder den ich gelesen habe oder die
gesprochen haben und in denen nicht
verteidigt habe und und diese
unterschiedlichen fälle tausche ich
alles aus also orte und namen und zwar
nur der grundton bleibt ja also
der ton dieser geschichte aber was so
passiert
und bei dieser geschichte ist es ebenso
dieser man begeht die straftat und er
fühlt sich nicht schuldig findet er hat
das richtige getan und und und das ist
auch ein problem das wir oft haben also
dass das menschen straftaten begehen so
sie sehen es im wirtschaftsstrafrecht
ganz oft ja also ein unternehmer oder
ein manager begeht eine straftat und ich
habe nicht in vielen aber in einigen
wirtschaftsstrafverfahren verteidigt und
ich habe noch nie jemanden erlebte
gesagt okay des balls falsch sondern 95
prozent der leute sagen in diesen
wirtschaftsstrafverfahren auch alles
richtig was ich gemacht habe
ich wusste ist und es war vollkommen in
ordnung gibt es leider auch noch mal
zurück zur schuld also die sagen der
wurde oder wird er verurteilt also das
heißt zu sagen juristisch wird der
schuldig gesprochen
ist ja auch moralisch schuldig das
überlasse ich wirklich dem leser also
das ist ja das ist eine frage die die
sie entscheiden müssen ja also die die
moralische schuld ist sehr veränderlich
ja also das was wir vor 400 jahren als
moralisch verwerflich angesehen haben
sehen wir heute überhaupt nicht mehr
sexuelle verkehr zwischen zwei männern
abtreibungen alle möglichen anderen
wurden damals als das schlimmste was es
gibt einen berühmten fall von von 57
glaube ich 1957
da ließ sich eine frau sterilisieren und
das gericht verurteilte sie mit der
begründung diese sterilisation war nur
dazu da dass sie freien sexuellen
verkehr haben darf das muss man sich mal
vorstellen das war ist keine 100 jahre
her so 50 jahre
und und die die idee unsere einem
moralischen schuld wechsel von
jahrhundert zu jahrhundert manchmal auch
innerhalb von zehn jahren ja dass
deswegen überlasse ich das dem leser
rechtlich wäre er ganz sicher verurteilt
worden jetzt kann man sich ja fragen
wenn dir nicht wirklich urteilen wollen
ob jemand moralisch schuldig ist wozu
eigentlich strafe da ist weil man kann
ja strafen um prävention zu betreiben
aber es gibt ja auch die idee das
straffe täglich dazu dienen soll sich zu
rechnen oder den sie nie gedanken
voranzutreiben
ja das ist eine eine ernste und
unwirklich sehr gute frage und uns
unglaublich schwer das zu beantworten
also wir haben zunächst einmal zwei
straff zwecke die die ganz klar sind das
ist die juristen die eine die spezial
prävention das bedeutet sie begehen sie
klauen ein kaugummi der richter bestraft
zieht damit sie nicht noch mal einen
kaugummi klauen das ist das was man mit
kleinen kindern macht oder mit runden
oder so etwas
und das zweite ist eine eine
generalprävention sie trauen diesen
kaugummi der richter bestraft sieht
damit anderen nicht den club auch
kaugummis clown also sozusagen eine
abschreckung ja eine generalprävention
und neben diesen zwei strafzeiten gibt
es noch noch den dritten das ist dass es
die söhne ja oder oder wenn man es böse
unangenehmer sagen will die rache ja das
ist sehr ähnlich der söhne gedanke und
daran und und damit ist es schwer ja
also das ist auch schwer einzuordnen und
und ich mag es eigentlich nicht auf der
anderen seite dient das recht auch dazu
rechtsfrieden herzustellen und und wenn
sich es gibt viele leute die denken wenn
wir nur den nur diese
präventionsgedanken verfolgen stellt
sich keinen rechtsfrieden ein waldes in
der bevölkerung
den wunsch gibt dass der aus einem söhne
gedanken der soll jetzt ins gefängnis
derart böses getan ja jede der in der
strafjustiz arbeitet weist dass das mit
dem gefängnis keine so wahnsinnig gute
idee ist die leute werden mich besser im
gefängnis sondern es wird schlechter
viele gerne mit ihnen jemandem zuhören
nämlich dieter burkhardt das ist ein
raubmörder der 25 jahre im gefängnis
saßen der war zu gast bei uns in einer
sternstunde der nacht zum thema das böse
die man auch weiter online sehen kann
und in dieser sendung hat er etwas genau
zu dieser frage gesagt letztendlich
glaube ich dass strafen nur dann gerecht
sein können wenn sie die menschen in ihr
positives potenzial zurückzuführen
versuchen daran scheitert der
strafvollzug sehr oft weil ja strafe
zurück ja zum teil auch befriedigung des
rachebedürfnis ist was psychologisch
durchaus in ordnung ist was
gesellschaftlich aber grenzwertig ist
weil werfen wir einen blick nach
albanien da gibt es ganze dörfer da
gibt's keine männer mehr weil und frauen
verkleidet sich als männer um die
blutrache weiterführen zu können
das passiert wenn man gesellschaftlich
rache als probates mittel anerkennt ich
glaube dass wir letztendlich auf dem
richtigen weg sind
dass wir aber jetzt gerade in
entwicklungs schwierigkeiten stecken und
wir weitergehen müssen darin das
potenzial in jedem menschen zu sehen und
ich finde da hat norwegen uns mit
mittelmäßigen fantastisches beispiel
geliefert wo sich eine gesamte
gesellschaft geweigert hat sich von
einem einzelnen mann neue gesetze
diktieren zu lassen gesagt nein wir
glauben weiter an das gute im menschen
und wir lassen uns das nicht von
einzelnen stören
ja das ist interessant aber es ist fast
alles falsch
ja also der staat gibt keine blutrache
deswegen ist das beispiel mit albanien
vollkommener blödsinn
es ist es ist so dass dass die
bevölkerung einen gewissen anspruch
darauf hat ja auch auf die bühne und man
glaubt dass ich halte es für keine
wahnsinnig gute idee weil es auch
langfristig nicht funktioniert dass es
der hauptgrund dagegen und ist es wird
auch immer weniger ja aber dieses dieses
bedürfnis gibt es aber die justiz
kanalisiert das und und das ist schon
ganz in ordnung
andreas breivik hat damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun ja es geht bei andreas
privates war das bedeutende die
ansprache des damaligen
ministerpräsidenten ist es ging ja darum
was macht man jetzt mit der gesellschaft
in zukunft und und das entschied
stolberg ist der ministerpräsident ein
junger mann
ich mag ihn sehr gerne in kluger mann
und er sagte wir dürfen uns nicht
sozusagen von von so einer
terroristischen straftat was ja war
letztlich und diktieren lassen wir
unsere gesellschaft in zukunft
organisieren also dass wir das wir
körperscanner vorschulen aufstellen dass
wir noch strengere regularien an
flughäfen und so weiter und das hat
norwegen nicht gemacht und es war sehr
trug das nicht zu machen ja da sind wir
immer in gefahr
also vielleicht und dass das ist das
interessante wissen sie wir sind bedroht
von von terroristen ja also predigt war
jetzt nicht irgendwie war seine ideen
waren so würde dass man sie vielleicht
noch nicht mal mehr terroristisch nennen
kann
aber wir sind ja dauernd bedroht von von
terroristen
und trotzdem können die unsere
demokratien nicht zerstören das können
nur wir selbst ja das können nur wir
demokraten und zwar indem wir indem wir
so viele dinge gegen die terroristen tun
ja also unsere handys abhören unsere
e-mails lesen dass wir das den
geheimdiensten erlauben und so weit dass
wir am schluss unsere freiheit verlieren
und das ist immer die große gefahr
und das ist das erstaunliche bei preh
wie das dass eine nation mit diesem
ministerpräsidenten damals gesagt nein
belassen wir lassen das nicht zu ja da
ging das haben wir nicht unser ja
sondern diese allein sagt noch mal zur
rache zurückkommen mich interessiert zum
beispiel der von rupperswil er gab auch
sehr sehr viel zu reden der schweiz da
hat jemand vier menschen getötet zuerst
den jungen noch missbraucht das haus
wurde danach angezündet und es ging eine
weile bis man den täter gefasst hat ein
schreckliches verbrechen grauenhaft und
wenn man jetzt nicht darüber legen würde
mit ihrer unterscheidung der beiden
formen der prävention was man ja sagen
könnte man steckt auch so ein verbrecher
in ein hochsicherheitsgefängnis das aber
ausgestattet ist wie ein hotel das ist
irgendwie wunderbar wir können ganz
sicher sein die ausbrecher die diese tat
nie wieder begehen und so jenseits von
freiheit zu leben das ist auch
vielleicht genug am präventionsgedanke
für die ganze gesellschaft niemand
möchte einfach eingesperrt in einem
hotel sein
aber dann würden doch viele sagen nein
dem sei es auch schlecht gehen im
gefängnis der soll auch wirklich
bestraft werden im sinne dieser dieses
sühne gedankens und wir könnten
vielleicht auch sagen mehr so im sinne
von immanuel kommt es geht auch darum
wieder etwas ins gleichgewicht zu
bringen kann sie diese idee gar nichts
abgewinnen
doch ich sagte ihm ja das ist dass die
bevölkerung einen anspruch darauf hat
auch auf diesen rechtsfrieden und dass
der auch so hergestellt wird
ich will das mal andersrum sagen
oft genug macht das fernsehen ja auch
oder auch andere journalisten machen
bericht über gefängnisse vitrolles den
dort geht dass sie einen tennisplatz
haben und ein schwimmbad oder das
entspricht nicht meiner erfahrung also
gefangen gefängnis ist nach wie vor üble
ort in die man nicht will
ich sage ihnen ein ganz kleines beispiel
ich hatte einen war auch ein unternehmer
der für kurze zeit wegen einer
steuerstraftat ins gefängnis kamen und
und erzählt mir immer wie der wieder
wachtmeister ihn zu der zelle gebracht
hat und dann die tür aufgemacht hat und
dann hatte ihm einen ganz leichten
schubs gegeben das war nicht schlimm ist
ja aber es so dass er so ein schritt in
diese zelle rein machen muss und diese
kleine shops hat diesen mann über jahre
beschäftigt ja das war das war für ihn
eine solche demütigung raus zu fallen
aus seiner welt plötzlich und dass
irgend jemand in eine zelle reihen
schubsen da das bedeutet gar nichts und
die zelle war okay da stand ein bett
drin und es gab eine toilette genau und
und dass sie plötzlich die auf einer
kleinen raum mit sich vollkommen alleine
sind
das ist äußerst brutal davon abgesehen
ist es auch so dass ihr umgang den sie
dort in seinem gefängnis habe nicht
besonders angenehm ist ja sondern
sondern meistens noch ziemlich
scheußlich ist aber dass das problem ist
gefängnisse sind also üble orte und es
ist und es ist für die für fast alle
menschen schrecklich in einem gefängnis
zu sein dass es keine wohltat die an der
stad an gedeihende und darüber darf man
sich auch nicht täuschen und ja ich
wollte nur ein hat man darf sich darüber
nicht täuschen die es den menschen da
geht und sie plädieren ja eben auch
immer wieder dass jemand darf sich auch
nicht darüber täuschen was die motive
von menschen
weil menschen unterschiedliche sachen
erleben unterschiedlich leiden unter
gewissen dingen und sie haben ein
wunderbares gespräch geführt mit
alexander kluge das trägt den titel die
herzlichkeit der vernunft ein gespräch
zwischen ihnen beiden
und darin gibt es auch diese beobachtung
dass sie sagen wir sollten dazu
übergehen wie dann weniger zu urteilen
und mehr zu beobachten ist das hat das
wie die quintessenz aus
ja das ist bisschen die quitten sind aus
meinem leben ja also wir sind ja bereit
sofort alles zu beurteilen ja also wir
sitzen im kaffeehaus an einem tisch
niemand geht vorbei der eine grüne hose
trägt und man denkt oh gott was ist das
für ein typ dann kann man nur eine
hellgrüne rosa an haben ja und das ist
die falsche haltung zur welt ja also
alles wird interessant wenn sie
möglichst wenig urteilen und nur zu sie
ja das ist sozusagen das schöne dann am
leben das sie sie sitzen in derselben
situation im kaffeehaus ein ein mann der
ganz gruselig aussieht setzt sich an
ihren tisch weil kein anderer mehr frei
ist und erzählt ihnen etwas und alles
daran ist interessant und wenn sie ihn
aber wenn sie alles beurteilen würden
wenn sie kein wort mit ihm sprechen und
ihn wegschicken wurde selbst gehen wenn
es nicht anders geht
also es ist eine art freundlichkeit dem
leben gegenüber wenn wir wenn wir ein
bisschen weniger ohne urteil gekommen
bin ich aus aber es ist ganz vernünftig
das ist interessant was von einem
strafverteidiger zu hören ein
strafverteidiger urteilen nicht sind
keine richter ja es stimmt ich wäre ein
wahnsinn ich schlechter richter ich
würde mich so schwer tun
über das schicksal eines menschen zu
entscheiden aber im gerichtssaal geht es
um diese klarheit haben sie gesagt ja
aber ich bin nur auf einer seite ich
also im deutschen strafrecht ist es so
dass das der richter und der
staatsanwalt keine parteien sind ja in
amerika ist der staatsanwalt eine partei
und der verteidigung im deutschen
gerichtswesens ist der verteidiger die
einzige partei seine einzige aufgabe ist
es für den mandanten zu sprechen er
kämpft sozusagen für den man dann und
das ist eine haltung die ich ganz gerne
habe er also ich wäre ich wäre nicht ich
wäre nicht gut im urteil ich möchte das
auch nicht und was ist wenn sie jemanden
verteidigen müssen oder mussten von dem
sie eigentlich wissen der ist schuldig
aber sie versuchen ja trotzdem in seinem
sinne das beste daraus zu holen
das ist eine frei zu kriegen und das ist
ein welches zu sagen doch das
intellektuelle fehlschluss also bin ich
ein wenn ich ein mandat übernehmen
dann habe ich wie sie wahrscheinlich
auch ja so ein gefühl ja wahrscheinlich
war das ja aber ich bin nicht derjenige
der über urteilt ob er schuldig ist oder
nicht das kann nur ein richter am
schluss solange ich den verteidiger ist
er unschuldig ja und er wird erst
schuldig wenn der richter das sagt ja
also ich könnte es ich könnte es noch
extremer sagen ich könnte sagen ich habe
nie ein marder verteidigt der
freigesprochen worden ist sondern wenn
er freigesprochen worden ist war kein
würde aber das widerspricht auch unserer
intuition und es gibt auch diese
geschichte volksfest in der sie erzählen
die eine frau von einer blaskapelle
brutal misshandelt jetzt am rande eines
volksfest und schlussendlich kann man
denen allen nicht das nachweisen was es
bräuchte um sie zu verurteilen und sie
kommen alle frei und trotzdem würde ich
auch sagen das ist doch nicht gerecht
doch das ist seltsamerweise gerecht ja
genau das ist gerecht also das ist ein
fall in dem alle also acht leute haben
dieses mädchen vergewaltigt aber neun
bahn in diese blaskapelle einer von den
hat bei der polizei angerufen war nicht
an der vergewaltigung beteiligt und
ergibt sich aber nicht zu erkennen die
waren alle maskiert ja und jetzt nimmt
die polizei alle neuen fest und von den
jeder der eine unschuldig sind seien
also acht waren schuldig aber jeder kann
der eine unschuldige sein und deswegen
müssen alle freigesprochen werden das
ist hart und das ist dass das finden wir
furchtbar und das ist geistig aber es
ist gerecht
das muss ich jetzt erst mal sacken
lassen sich aussagen darin ich an carla
del ponte die natürlich immer dafür
plädiert hat zu sagen wir müssen für die
opfer sprechen und sie müssen für
gerechtigkeit sprechen auch im sinne von
musikern nicht unschuldige verurteilen
und das gerät das ist absolut richtig
und und und natürlich es geht in einem
gerichtsverfahren immer um die opfer ja
aber die die vorstellung dass ein
richter sich um die opfer kümmert ist
auch unsinn in einem strafverfahren ein
richter ist dazu da über die schuld
eines angeklagten zu entscheiden nicht
wie es dem opfer geht
dafür sind andere dafür haben wir eine
fülle von von institutionen die sich um
das opfer kümmerte richtet ist kein
psychologe kann gelingen im aufwändig
und und das merkwürdige ist auch wenn
sie wenn sie lange strafverteidigung
machen
merken sie dass es da auch zwei ganz
unterschiedliche typen von opfern gibt
ja also die die einen sind immer empört
ja egal auch wenn der lebenslang bekommt
werden sie empört weil es immer noch
nicht genug ist ja und die anderen die
meistens etwas kühleren die interessiert
wie es passiert ist und das ist ein das
ist etwas was wir vom strafverfahren
erwarten und auch das ja wieder das
genaue beobachten wir dass zum schluss
mit herr von schirach ist es glaube ich
mal einen tag lang weniger zu urteilen
und mehr zu beobachten wir alle sehr
interessanter sagt ja unbedingt
ich danke ihnen sehr für dieses gespräch
in den dank auch nächste woche widmen
jungs existenziellen fragen wolfram
eilenberger spricht mit verena kast und
wilhelm
mit über die traurigkeit am 31 oktober
ist es wieder zeit für den
philosophischen stammtisch und zwar zu
einem heiß diskutierten thema nämlich
der prostitution
wenn sie wissen wollen dass philosophen
zum geschäft mit der lust meinen seien
sie leicht mit dabei tickets gibt es
online und jetzt gleich geht es um
dieses ding hier um die box in den 1920
er jahren erfand der wahl-schweizer
chabrols sehe die legendäre filmkamera
die bis heute im jura produziert wird
unser film erzählt die geschichte der
berühmten alex viel vergnügen damit und
eine gute woche
[Musik]